[Music]  last week hasbro announced a big change  to their board game monopoly okay it's  official this game's been around since  the depression since the 1930s and now  they're they're getting rid of the  flatiron game piece they're getting rid  of it yes and they are replacing it with  the game piece of a cat  yeah wow yeah a lot of shut-ins here  yeah i know  right right kitty yeah kitties uh yeah  so the iron piece the flat iron piece  which has been a part of the game since  the very beginning is out but not giving  up that's right the iron is trying to  win its way back into our hearts by  launching its own internet videos  designed to make it as popular as cats  it's a crazy idea  i don't think it's going to work  [Applause]  [Music]  available for adoption he's great with  kids and picky piggy settle down what's  up piggy  get it off me get it off me